ومن الخبر العاجل الذي وردنا الان عن
الاذاعه الاسرائيليه و يفيد بمقتل
فلسطينيين اثنين واصابه ثلاثه مستوطنين في
عمليه طعن بجنوبس
رام الله مراسله الجزيره سمير ابو شماله
سمير ما هي تفاصيل
يعني وفقا للاذاعه الاسرائيليه وبيان لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الاوليه يتحدث عن
عمليتي طعن نفذتها بالقرب من المستوطنه
ومستوطنتي اليه ذهاب الواقعه بين نابلس
ومحافظه سلفيت في وسط الضفه الغربيه هناك
الحديث يدور عن العمليه الاولى ان هناك
شاب فلسطيني قد ايه طعن احد المستوطنين في
الجزء العلوي بالجسده واصابه بالجروح خارج
للغايه حسب ما افادت بها المصادر الطبيه
وربماته تكون حالته ميؤوس منها وتم تحييد
المنفذ الهجوم حسب تعبير بيان جيش
الاحتلال حيث تم اطلاق النار عليه وتحديده
وذلك يحمل بانه ربما يكون مقتله بشكل
مباشر او بسبقه بس اجره الحديثه عن
استشهاد العمليه الاولى وهل هناك ايضا
عمليه اخرى وقعت بالقرب من احد محطات
الوقود
احدى المستوطنتين وقد تم طعن همم الاثنين
من المستوطنين وصفات لجراحه احدهم
بالخطيره جدا والاخرى خطيره وتم نقلهمم
بالاسعاف لتلقي العلاج وقد تمكن من المنفذ
الاخر من الهروب من المكان ولكن تم
ملاحقته من قوه من قبل القوات الامن
الاسرائيليه
بهذه الحاله كان هناك عمليه محاوله لسرقه
سياره من منفذ الهجوم كانت تصطفل الى جانب
الطريق وقد دخل الى الشارع رقم خمسه هناك
كان قد وقع حادث السير وخرج الشاب وهمم
اطلاق النار عليه وتحيده في هذا المكان
هذه المعلومات الاوليه الوارده من عمليه
لقد هما شابين فلسطينيين في محيط
المستوطنتي ارئيل وذهاف اليزا هاف في
الواقعتين جنوب مدينه نابلس والقريبه ايضا
من محافظه سلفيت قوات الامن الاسرائيليه
نشرت قواتها في المكان وتقوم بعمليات
تمشيط في المكان للبحث عن المنفذين اخرين
ان كانت تواجد هناك لمنافدين
المنفذين وايضا ذوقم الاسعاف الاسرائيليه
هي نقلت ال ال الحالات الحرجه والاصابات
الى المستشفيات الاسرائيليه لي التلقي
العلاج هذه الحاله الامنيه التي تشهدها
تلقى المنطقه هناك تطبيق المنطقه السير
ربما يرفع عدد الاصابات بين المستوطنين في
همم هذه المركبات التي تم تصادم من خلال
هروب المنفذ الثاني من عمليات الطعن التي
تم قتله في همم المكان واذا تم ال- ال-
الاعلان الرس عن استشهاد هذين
الفلسطينيين وهذا هذا الاعلان هو من
المصادر الاسرائيليه يرتفع عدد الشهداء في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه مما في ذلك القطاع غزه
الى نحو 200 همم شهيد منذ بدايه هذا العام
هذه المعلومات الوارده حتى الان من
المنطقه التي وقعت في عمليتي الطعن في ضد
اسرائيليين جزيلا لك سمير ابو شماله من
رام الله